but I thought there was an actual nice
moment of politics this week related to
Trump and DeSantis which is kind of rare
these days uh this was at a DeSantis
event a couple days ago in South
Carolina a trump voter a previous Trump
voter uh after listening to DeSantis and
I I think there's something to this
provided to come
to listen to you
when representative Moss
um I'm a very hardcore Trump supporter
but I know
he made me stop and think a minute
because my love for president Trump
comes from all the despair all the
things that he's been through has served
as our president of the United States
and he did a good job
but all the things I'm thinking more
with my heart and my sorrow and my love
for him and for this country but now I
have this is the most important vote
that we're going to have and I have to
think more with my mind and what's best
for this country and you did an
excellent job and I certainly God bless
you thank you
[Music]
and I appreciate that
and um you know I agree with you I
appreciate what president Trump did uh
how they treated him with things like
Russia collusion was a disgrace and um
and he was treated wrong uh he was
treated in ways that were
unconstitutional uh but here's the thing
the question for us now is what are we
going to do about it and we need to end
the weaponization of government I will
get that done it's not about me it's
about you it's about me standing up for
you and standing up for this
Constitution and restoring this country
to what the founding fathers Envision
and and we will we will get it done we
will be focused we will be disciplined
and we will make it happen Michael let
me start with you on that one I thought
it was a nice moment because I thought
that that woman in a very emotional way
captured what a lot of people feel right
now which is there's a huge appreciation
for Trump he doled out more red pills
than any of us could for the rest of our
lives all of that kind of thing and then
she's saying but I but I sort of feel
like moving on and that DeSantis then
basically was like I appreciate him too
I think I'm the guy and to me that's I
get primaries we're all going to shred
each other but to me that strikes the
tone that I actually think most people
want to hear what do you think it was a
great moment the whole event was really
good for DeSantis even in in the way
that he reacted to the news of the
indictment and he was reacting on the
fly but but he did so in a way that was
gracious and still has this problem
though which is we're all still talking
about exchange which is heartfelt she
says I'm going to vote for Yuna it's all
still about Trump so I I think it was
really good and he the thing he struck
on that really could resonate and really
could be a new path for his campaign is
if he Taps into what Trump did in 2016
which is it's not about me it's about
you Hillary says I'm with her I say I'm
with you and you just totally take that
ego out of it you take that personality
out of it that can be really charming
and persuasive and and offer a choice
not an echo if DeSantis continues to run
his Trump 2.0 bigger better faster
stronger he's going to lose because even
if New Coke tastes better than old Coke
people want old Coke they want the OG if
DeSantis really strikes this difference
and you see him starting to do that in
this answer then maybe you've got a real
alternative and then you've maybe got a
viable path to the nomination
foreign